l'été c'est la saison des festivals des
festivals d'humour des festival western
un festival de la poutine et beaucoup de
festivals de musique ça veut dire plein
de spectacles de la musique forte
parfois peut-être un peu trop forte
c'est par heure pendant la période des
festivals ou un peu après que les gens
viennent nous consulter vont nous dire
mais moi j'ai un acouphène à cette
oreille depuis que je suis allé à tel
spectacle de musique alors que le haut
parleur tes plats fait de ce côté là
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
la fréquentation régulière des concerts
peut être une cause de perte auditive
parce qu'on estime qu'un spectacle de
musiques amplifiées émet environ 110
décibels soit ces dix décibels de plus
qu'une scie à chaîne
mais dix décibels de moins qu'une sirène
de véhicules d'urgence restez forts 110
décibels si on pense par exemple à la
réglementation dans le milieu du travail
au québec on va considérer comme
sécuritaires une personne qui s'expose à
90 décibels pendant une période de 8 ans
chaque fois qu'on va augmenter de 5
décibels on va devoir à ce moment le
coupé le temps d'exposition de 95
décibels
à ce moment le ce serait seulement
quatre heures à 100 décibels ce serait
seulement deux heures
105 une heure donc si on arrive aux 110
on parle d'à peu près 1 30 minutes
d'exposition qu'on pourrait considérer
comme sécuritaires bon il faut pas pour
autant partir en courant après une
demi-heure le spectacle mais il ya des
moyens simples d'éviter de nuire à la
santé aurait commencé par s'éloigner des
haut parleurs porter des bouchons et
éviter d'assister à des spectacles
pendant plusieurs jours consécutifs
question de donner une petite pause à
votre système auditif ce qui a aidé
aussi quand on parle de spectacles
extérieurs c'est que les niveaux sonores
sont souvent réglementée par exemple
l'arrondissement ville-marie où se
trouve la place des festivals à montréal
impose pour les grands événements une
limite de 90 civils quand on se trouve à
35 mètres des haut parleurs
on a des sonomètres manuel qu'on va
utiliser de façon ponctuelle à certains
endroits stratégiques pour avoir une
idée de ce qu'on a comme niveau sonore
depuis quelques temps aussi les
commentaires se sont eux-mêmes munis
d'appareils de mesure une bonne manière
d'avoir une mesure objective des niveaux
de sang ce moment là parce que ça peut
dépendre de loudes star
ses préférences mais quoi faire si
malgré tout cela vous sortez d'un
spectacle et vous avez l'impression vos
horizons bouchés
si le lendemain quelques jours après on
n'a pas de récupération on re conseillé
de consulter parce que ça peut être un
indice qui ont un traumatisme sonore qui
s'est installée dans le réel
donc oui il faut rester vigilant mais
non ça veut pas dire d'éviter les
spectacles de musique pour le reste de
vos jours
on est tous allés dans des spectacles
qu'on est tous allés dans des bars dans
notre vie fixer un moment donné faut pas
non plus rester dans notre maison a rien
fait
[Musique]